there used to be a time when you and I
heard of or net worth all we ever
thought about is a dollar sign because
we linked network to money I will
explain two networks in a way that's
completely different because today your
network has a complete different meaning
and it's good news for you
but hang tight before I get into it so
it's 1999 and I'm 21 years old this is a
story I want to tell you and I got out
of the army and I'm in Hollywood I'm in
LA every time I go out I see valet with
Lamborghini and Ferrari and Bentley's
and Porsches and all these exotic sign I
want one of these cars I want to become
million or myself as well and I find
this one man who's wealthy and I pull
them aside said you might have lunch
with us lunch with me
and the entire time during lunch I kept
asking how do you become a millionaire
how did you become a million how'd you
become I'm 21 naive don't have a clue on
what's going on right and he finally
stops me such man you're asking
everything around money how do I get
complete in a wrong way it would mean by
this he says look let me just explain to
you this way
he says if I was to take this hand right
now and if I were to cover your mouth
and your nose what would you be thinking
about aside to be thinking about air he
says you know why I said because I don't
have any of it this is of course you
says you know why all you think about is
money
I said why he's is because you have none
of it all you're thinking about is money
because you have none of it so you are
allowing this money problem to prevent
you from ever finding out your purpose
in life you said you got to get this
money problem squared away quickly you
just think about it this way how much
access to oxygen do you have right now I
said unlimited you said you would go
bragging to people about how much oxygen
how much do you go to people as well
like this do you brand do you show off I
said no this is the same thing with
money he says hurry up and get your
money prompt squared away but he
explained it in a way that I realized it
wasn't just about money it was something
bigger than money so today if you're not
a dekha million I know we have several
billionaires and several people follow
this vitamin channel who are worse than
the hundreds if not tens of millions of
dollars but I'm talking to the guys who
maybe don't have the millions
let me explain it in a complete
different way your net for today is four
different brackets okay
one is the actual money okay the other
one is your help the other one is a
skill then the other one is your
influence and your voice let me explain
this is a byproduct of these three not
the other way around this comes because
of these three this is just one aspect
of your network a person could be very
wealthy dying no longer can applying a
skillset and it all gets influenced on
voice because you can't speak anymore
that money doesn't mean anything today
right so let's talk about these three
areas health it's part of your net worth
why if you are if you can move if you
can talk if you can see this video if
you can hear me if you can comprehend if
your brain can process all the
information is taking us in I don't
believe this I don't believe in it I
like this this is amazing never heard
this before this is cool what if I did
this let me write this and I process
this part if your brain can do if your
heart can feel if you're feeling the
emotion right if you can walk if you can
go around if you can help you can do all
that other stuff it's part of your
network you need to make sure you take
your body fat because it helps you with
stamina energy can last a lot longer the
longer you can last and more possibility
able making money the other one asked
you if Edgar back here standing right
back there Edgar knows how to use camera
to come to you and tells me all this if
thinks about cameras these over here
knows how to do the sound all the other
guys do know how to do a certain skill
set there forever going to be fine
because they have a skill set that's
part of their network you're buying a
skill this human being is like imagine
you have a country and everybody lost
everything and you're trying to go live
on this country what question are they
going to ask you before they let you
come into this country how much money
are you bringing to this country what's
the other thing
what do you know what skills do you have
why does it country ask that because
it's part of your network we want some
skills to come into the country and last
but not least is your influence on voice
let me explain something you if somebody
all of a sudden their influence goes up
social media Twitter YouTube doesn't
matter if their influence suddenly goes
up you better believe money follows and
a lot of people surprising you're not
paying attention to this today several
people are figuring it up but some are
still moving way too slow on in folsom
voice think about the guy that's a
today he had more influence and you know
how to use his voice even though it
ticked off half the population so let's
influence envoys Twitter instead
Facebook uses email telling your story
telling the arguments having your
thoughts that's part of your influence
on your voice these three contribute
towards your financial network but
they're part of your total network this
is a package nobody just gets it with
only one now if you were watching this
video because you're pure interest was
around money let me explain - on the
financial side on what your net worth
has to do with four different areas one
is your credit score then its savings
then its income Venice investment a lot
of times people will say well the most
important thing is your savings or the
most important thing is your investments
my dad would say credit is the most
important thing no it's about making
money so what is the most important
thing every one of them matters every
one of them matters
credit today when we started a PHP
agency' the insurance agency financial
firm every insurance company that wanted
to give us contracts they did every type
of background check on me misdemeanor
felony DUI credit late payment on this
I'm talking every single thing and it
would come back like this okay so if I
doesn't have a good credit I don't get
those contracts because I don't have a
good credit your credit has to do with
the money the bank's willing to pay you
a car loan a house on a business loan
everything comes back to how solid of a
credit you have it's that important
some people don't pay attention to this
it hurts you you need to pay attention
to your credit the other part is saving
what is the important thing about
savings right why white things white
savings so important saving helps this
work better the more savings you have a
place think about it this way imagine
you're about to get into a fight with a
guy that's twice your size okay
and you go by yourself and you don't
know how to fight and that guy knows
martial arts mixed martial art what's
going to happen with this are you pretty
confident you're going to go to this guy
and he's going to come he's going to do
a couple kicks you're done now let me
give you some backing you're going to go
fight that guy except you got a hundred
people that are willing to come with you
as well and all those hundred people are
bigger than you and you go to that guy
he's by himself
twice as big as you but you got a
hundred people behind you so you want to
fight looks like it's just wait a minute
I came to fight one-on-one no I came to
leverage I brought leverage you don't
have leverage I have leverage you want
to fight let's go this guy's not going
to fight you
why because yes hey savings gives you
leverage savings gives you backing
saving just those hundred people
standing behind you where people say I'm
not going to mess with you or I'm going
to do business with you because you've
got a lot of Basking that staging
savings allows you to process things
better
saving the allows you to make better
decisions lead better every single way
you become a better seal you become a
better executive you become a better
recruit or better salesman if you have
savings in this place and savings and
splitting different brackets it's not
all checking account you got to make
sure short term sticking to your mid
term long term if you're single right
now much I don't have any kids I don't
have to worry about my kids then it's
all short to fine if you got kids you're
married you got to make sure miss them
if you got an eight-year-old daughter
ten years of college that's 18 years old
you got to think about these types of
things if you got a 16 year old daughter
10 years 26 marriage in your culture do
you pay do they pay how much you need to
set aside is 50,000 a wedding I don't
know those numbers but you need to be
prepared for because that time is coming
very very quickly and it's long-term
retirement investments all that other
stuff so short term is 0 to 12 months
miss term is a year to 10 years long
term is 10 plus years and then we have
income let's talk about income sometimes
income I have an income at $100,000
income but it's only an active income if
I stop working I don't make it and then
the other side is a passive income but
it's only $1,000 a month so what's
important it's important to have both
I like active and I like past it some
people will tell you you want to have
multiple streams of income and I get
questions all the time Pat do you know I
want to do the right but I want seven
different businesses to pay me because
imagine there's always just one guy that
wants to do it the fastest way to become
rich I want to do it so I'm going to get
ten different businesses and intended
from this if each of them paid me a
thousand dollars I want to be a
multimillionaire one day listen don't
listen to that guy do not listen to that
guy before you have a very strong
passive income you got to have
one solid one solid solid income that's
coming in solid you don't want to go to
many multiple streams of income and
they're all ten percent 10% ten percent
10% ten percent I would much rather have
one stream of income that's 90 percent
and it's strong that can feed others
then try to do ten ten ten ten ten I
wouldn't take it that route so income is
extremely critical because this helps
with the others and last but not least
investment stocks bonds stock options
real estate artwork portfolios that have
to do with certain baseball cards
collectibles that you have that's
investments that's that's growing for on
you on a yearly basis so now okay
perfect now how do I increase my net
worth and you may say hey I'm worth two
billion dollars today one worth 100
million today I'm worth 10 million today
I almost a million or you may say how
much fifty thousand what do I do with
this no problem
first of all take this out we have a
sheet for you to download if you're on
patro beta vidcom you should see it all
the way in the bottom if you don't you
need to go to Patrick beta be calm to
the link and just search this if you
don't see it already searched going to
the bottom there's a PDF download the
PDF when you download this PDF write
down your credit score what is your
credit score right here write down your
credit score write down your income
active-passive write down your savings
short-term mid-term long-term write down
your investments how much you have in
your investment write those numbers up
look at it how do you feel about it
that's the first thing okay
second thing is start tracking it on the
monthly basis every single month start
tracking it I started tracking this back
in 2004 when I realized I had hit rock
bottom I had to start tracking I hit
rock bottom
August of all three I started tracking
Oh forth everything started change it so
start tracking then put a goal then you
drive it so it's right it out okay track
it put a goal drive it
what does drivers need you're driving
your credit score to go higher so if you
got a late fee from two years ago you're
actually going to contact for dealership
and say hey why did you put a late fee I
was never late
and they contact the bureau's then they
take it off your credit score's jumps up
17 points that's driving your credit
score how do you drive your income how
can I get paid more on my job how can I
make more money as my company I'm
working at how can I make more you're
driving your income you're driving your
passive income you're driving it right
same with savings same with investments
now same way you're doing this I need
you to also do the same thing on this
side on the same sheet of pickier
download a PDF document download it
right on your total network network this
assets minus liabilities right so if you
have a hundred thousand dollars in total
savings and your seventy thousand
dollars it's really thirty thousand
dollars your total net worth is what you
have right your influence your voice
write down how many people follow your
voice Facebook total followers okay
we're going to be in the bottom Twitter
total followers YouTube subscribers
email subscribers Instagram snapchat
write all of it in your box
what is the total amount of people that
are following you write that number in
here your hell how was your weight your
way to your height how's it looking have
you gone and measured it to see how it
looks how how's your body fat ones the
last time you went to the doctor and you
said I want to do complete body tests I
want to take a blood test here I want my
body fat and you start getting it every
three months you go to the doctor you do
your body fat you do blood SATs every
three month how's this looking how's
that looking how's this looking
you start tracking it you'll in this box
what are you an expert in write it in
that box I'm an expert at coding I'm an
expert at selling I'm an expert at this
I'm an expert in real estate I'm an
expert whatever it is write it in here
once you write it in there okay and you
look at this you'll say okay this makes
sense I have nine thousand two hundred
people that follow me I got thirty nine
thousand dollars of savings here my body
fat is 19% I've got work to do here
because I need to drop 22 pounds and
skills
honestly I mean I'm pretty good at
soccer but I'm not going to be a
professional soccer player I'm pretty
good with whatever it is but I gotta
figure this thing up that's the point
when you look at this and it's right in
front of you both of these you say man I
got some work to do so that's when you
add on this side what skills do you want
to ask
become an expert at it what is your goal
here how do you become an expert at it
what does your go here how do you drive
this how do you drive this so remember
goes back to the four things you first
write it out so you look at it till you
track it three you give it a goal or you
drive it you drive both of these all of
a sudden you notice your net worth
increasing and then you're looking back
five years from now ten years from now
saying holy moly I'm with 17 million
dollars I would six hundred and
ninety-three thousand dollars I'm worth
one hundred ninety three million dollars
how did this happen because you focus on
all of these these 42 different brackets
that you're looking at your focus on
these and things started changing
instead of the typical logical academia
way of you know in the box thinking of
network that's all tied to your money BS
this is all part of your network
don't let anybody for you that's all
school this is no school the only these
old school people teach you how to
increase your net worth to our still
stop making sixty-two thousand dollars
at a university or somewhere they're
teaching and they themselves going to
have a high net worth I want to tell you
how to get a high net work okay I'm just
telling me times have changed adjust
pivot the good news is now you have this
information what you do with it is
completely up to you
let's go let's get that pillow here kind
of like today's episode man today's
episode got me excited I think it's
something that a lot of people can truly
take advantage of so anyways what that
being said comment your thoughts and
your questions on the bottom by the way
if you haven't yet subscribed to this
channel this is our pillow we got from
my friend Jennifer Mack our goal is to
get 2 million subs by the end of 2017 we
firmly believe this is the best channel
on YouTube for entrepreneurship
best channel there's a lot of
motivational regurgitating you can do it
school sucks all this other stuff but
there's not how to do follow up with it
there's a lot of great daily vlogs that
you see people doing hey follow my life
all this other stuff show me how to do
it nothing wrong with all that stuff I
think snapchat itself is a daily blog in
here we want to show you how to do it
you can actually go up and get results
like tens of thousands of people all
right now from studying the content on
value Tim and so if you haven't
subscribe yet what are you waiting for
click on that button here
subscribe and then click on the
notification so you're one of the first
to get all the videos that's coming -
good catch Edgar with that being said
thanks so much for watching everybody
take care bye bye
[Music]